[Music]  what we're about to do will be perilous  [Music]  some of us won't be coming back  others may be devastated by what they've  witnessed  so if that's the case  what will we do  it's something i've always encouraged uh  well let up no we talk about it exactly  we talk it through  as approved  every pirate captain captains pirates  differently  traditionally piracy is a culture of  abuse  and my thought is why can't one be a  gentleman tend a pirate  swashbuckling let's have fun with it  this is how you die  [ __ ] is you supposed to be i'm steed  he's the gentleman pirate  you're an idiot  so he's a fancy man with a fancy [ __ ] hi  all  he travels with a brigade of imbeciles  do i have that knife  completely unprofessional fascinating  [Music]  you